a bit of breaking news to you bringing
out because a parole board has denied
the former Olympic Athlete Oscar
Pistorius early release from prison in
South Africa now of course Oscar
Pistorius was jailed in 2016 after being
found guilty of shooting and killing his
girlfriend Riva steenkamp at their home
in South
Africa we can go to our correspondent
now yusra albigu who is at the scene in
Pretoria usura tell us more
so yeah Oscar as you said has been
denied parole an officer from the
Department of Correctional Services just
came out and let us know in person that
he has been granted further profile now
what that means is essentially it's been
denied and he will have to reapply for
parole in August 2024 so we'll have to
wait until next year to put forward his
case again for release they've they've
stated that it is due to a
miscalculation inter that he hasn't
served his minimum requirement his
minimum time in prison there seems to
have been a miscalculation because that
was said in the past that he had served
his minimum term that he had served more
than half of his sentence so there seems
to be a discrepancy between what when
they are deciding he started his
sentence whether it was when he first
went to prison or when his his uh
sentencing was appealed in 2016 and he
went back to prison to serve an extended
sentence now this is where he served a
majority of his prison sentence it's
also where riva's mother June Stephen
Camp came today to present a victim
impact statement as how the murder of
her daughter at the hands of Pistorius
has affected her and her family we spoke
to her before she went in she said that
this was very stressful and I asked her
if she believes that Oscar is remorseful
or and she said no never he is not
remorseful and then she added or
rehabilitated the family had been
campaigning heavily that he is not only
not released on parole but also serves a
life sentence and they say that until he
admits that he had the intention of
murdering their daughter he could not
possibly be rehabilitated
you sir thank you very much indeed